for today Joseph oh no he's a professor
at NYU at the Courant Institute and tech
fellow our technical fellow at the
Electronic Frontier Foundation formerly
Oh Farley yeah yeah well I'm sure you're
doing this on what yeah
great okay so I'm gonna talk about
lotteries publicly verifiable lotteries
which is a another exciting thing
happening hopefully hopefully getting to
be a hotter topic never as hot as voting
but yes I will try to convince you that
that's true so already a good question I
haven't even gotten that's the first
slide okay so I guess I'll give you the
cryptographic abstraction of what a
perfect lottery would look like first
and then we'll sort of you know slowly
look at how we can build something like
that
so cryptographers came up with this idea
of a random to speakin I believe the
term dates back at least to the 80s you
can think of it kind of is an ideal
functionality or an Oracle that just
spits out randomness all the time at
regular intervals nobody can predict it
nobody can manipulate it everybody sees
the same randomness it should be
reliable it should always be accessible
and hopefully it produces lots of
randomness as much as you could ever
need so obviously if this object existed
that would be the end of the talk you
would drive your lottery based on this
random to speakin and that would be it
oh and I'll add one more property which
I won't talk too much about but I can't
stress enough whether or not you know
the public believed that this beacon was
actually legitimate would would of
course be important so there are a lot
of different things that you could build
or make better I mean I guess we know
how to do these things but we they would
be better if we had an ideal randomness
beacon a lot of reasons in the title
I'll show you why they're also useful
for zero knowledge
proofs and consensus protocols in
general although as I said I'm going to
show there's a little bit of a nexus
consensus protocols at least efficient
consensus protocols end up having a
lottery running under the hood wire
lottery is actually important you know
answer number one is that they're fun
humans have liked gambling for a really
long time that's very unlikely to change
so as long as people enjoy games that
are random whether they're for money or
just video games that are that are fun
where you want to face say a changing
map or whatever there's you know it's I
think that should be enough you know
reason in and of itself but there's also
social reasons that we want to have
lotteries because there's some resources
that are not not perfectly divisible for
example on the left here you can see
some people signing up registering for
the u.s. diversity Visa Lottery which is
a process the u.s. runs every year
50,000 visas are given out by lottery
usually there are somewhere between 3
and 5 million applications of which
50,000 are randomly chosen which are
then eligible to receive a green card
for the u.s. lots of other countries
also run immigration lotteries of one
form or another school lotteries are
really big there are a lot of
jurisdictions in the US and lots of
other places where spots and schools are
allocated by lottery and the common link
here is that you know you can't give
somebody well I guess you could sort of
give somebody a visa to live in a
country six months out of the year but
mostly people would like to move
completely so you know if three million
people sign up for 50,000 slots you
can't just give everybody a small
fraction of a visa so you know we
typically turn to lotteries in those
cases of course there's other ways you
could solve this problem you could try
to determine it based on some sort of
value or contest but in practice
lotteries are quite useful and then in
the middle there is sports of course
when you're running a big
sports tournament you have to decide who
plays who usually that involves the
lottery these are actually some of the
most high-profile lotteries that are
that are out there they're also a lot of
applications of lotteries that people
don't think of as lotteries because we
don't use the word lottery I would call
them negative lotteries but they include
deciding who gets picked for extra
security screening deciding whose taxes
get audited deciding who is subject to
the military draft in some cases that
hasn't been the case in the US since the
70s but we did do conscription via
lottery it's happened in other countries
as well so these are mathematically it's
exactly the same you have to randomly
pick some people out of the population
except I guess these are lotteries that
you don't want to win because they have
negative consequences but they're
important and in fact the Nexus to the
earlier talks we talked about you know
random or risk limiting audits for those
to be secured for election you want to
randomly select which votes you actually
audit after the fact right if you have
an adaptive adversary that knows which
votes are gonna be automated sorry with
if the adversary knows which votes are
gonna be audited they just wouldn't
cheat with those votes so I guess that
was kind of an interesting example this
morning of how a lot of security
protocols just assume you can randomly
audit something and that you know that
you'll have some security if that's the
case okay so this slide might be you
know fairly obvious if you have a
computer science background but if not I
guess I'm mostly just trying to convince
you that only one step of this is
actually hard from a computer science
standpoint if you want to run a
verifiable lottery but generally you
would publish some algorithm which is
the rules of the lottery for example in
the immigration example it's not as
simple as just picking 50,000 winners
out of three million applicants there
are caps on how many people from each
country can win and a number of other
small rules so you'd code all that up
you'd have a period where people can
audit and see that hopefully the
algorithm that you wrote down makes
sense and then when it's time to
actually do the lottery all you need is
a random seed in fact you only need a
very short random seed both
cryptographers would be happy if they
have 128 random bits and then you know
you can use a pseudo-random number
generator to do whatever you want with
an algorithm at that point so you have a
short random seed some Authority runs
the algorithm and then there's some
process for independent verification and
I guess going back to Ellie's talk
earlier this week or others there's a
lot of different ways you can imagine
verifying that this algorithm was run
correctly a proof could be provided it
could be R a tree executed etc ok so
like I said this is all you know fairly
mechanical the only really challenging
part is getting that random seed and
that's you know basically where I'll
focus for the rest of the talk but just
I guess for the non computer scientists
in the room actually
not sure I said there's a room mostly
computer scientists at this point
okay so being a computer science I know
what is a commitment sure sure okay yeah
well I guess this isn't really a
cryptographic commitment this is really
just publishing it on your website and
agreeing that that's what's gonna be run
and of course I'm leaving you know a
fair number of details out here but just
the high-level structure okay so I said
I would talk a little bit about some
other applications the connection
between randomness and zero knowledge
proof the basic structure of most or all
zero knowledge proof there's a verifier
who at least in an interactive proof
there's a verifier who makes some
queries of the proofer they get some
responses these queries have to be
randomized at least for the thing to be
zero knowledge so you know
conventionally these are usually
portrayed first as an interactive proof
and then you know we know the Piazza
Mirror transform can always make a non
interactive proof if you have randomness
beacon you can do a non interactive
proof I guess you also need you need a I
guess there should be a time stamping
service but you can you can get rid of
the Challenger completely you can just
have the approver publish some proof
commitment wait for the next time that
the beacon publishes and then
automatically extract from the
randomness that the beacon is publishing
a set of queries and then they can
answer those queries so in the case of a
blockchain you could think about
basically you know simulating the fact
that there's you know should be a
challenger but you're using some beacon
which you know show you later could be
generated from the blockchain so the
whole thing can just be published in in
that way and you could ask what's the
point of doing this and the reason
really is just that you need to answer a
few weak queries to get the same
soundness in the
case compared to doing Fiat Zamir with
Fiat schmear the prover is allowed to
grind and try to find a set of queries
that you know they can answer and in
this case they can't it's sort of a
one-shot opportunity for the approver so
I'm not aware of anybody actually doing
this on block chains even though it's
kind of an interesting idea actually if
anybody knows if this has been you know
it's it's been proposed off and on
several several times over the years but
I'm not sure if anyone has actually
started doing this I guess we should
have a lot of zero knowledge proof that
experts here so if no one in the room
has heard of such a thing then
specifically on them on a blockchain
using the blockchain yet to produce your
challenges and then sort of answering
them as yeah exactly yeah so yeah so
it's a neat idea maybe someday it's it's
day will come you know for hasn't come
yet but certainly a possibility
yeah so in the future when you really
like every block can be viewed as a
beacon up but then this might start to
look better okay and then other
application of randomness you can
consensus protocols so why is randomness
important for communication efficient
consensus protocols if you want to let
everybody talk then fine you don't you
know need randomness necessarily but
that requires everybody everybody to
communicate what most kind of box chain
you're a consensus protocols do is some
form of a random selection of a
committee of participants and this has
to be random and then this smaller
committee actually runs effectively a
consensus protocol and of course the
committee has to be big enough that you
know if you have an honest majority and
the full set of people you can still
assume an honest majority on the
committee and so forth but this you know
this basic structure of selecting a
small group from your full set of
possible validators and having them be a
committee shows up in lots and lots of
protocols in the blockchain space so
it's kind of a powerful idea
the miners yeah blocks in a minor in a
Bitcoin it is not random become why
isn't it well I'll get there I'll show
you some some problems with it but yeah
it's it's used as one but it's there's
some issues okay and the historical
analog of this really cool going back to
the Greeks who had the idea of randomly
selecting you know a parliament
effectively
I've never gotten a good explanation of
exactly how this device works but
involved citizens putting kind of a coin
in I'm Ratto Caen and then a random set
were chosen to serve as Parliament so
this is a cool historical idea called
sortition there are some political
scientists who've even proposed in the
modern era have said if we just had a
hundred random people be the US Senate
rather than people who've gone through
the process to become senators we would
actually possibly get a better result so
you know some people are convinced of
that but but who knows and so there's
kind of this trilemma
you know can't get all three between
your consensus protocol being efficient
communication wise doing kind of a
random subsampling of participants and
being adaptively secure so like i said
you know if we don't really care about
communication efficiency we've known how
to do byzantine fault tolerant consensus
for a long time the problem is that you
know classically everybody has to talk
and if you're not worried about adaptive
security you can just sort of run a
blockchain and rotate a different person
as the leader every time the problem is
that you know the in that case the
attacker sort of knows who's gonna be a
leader in future rounds and can corrupt
those people
so most protocols Lisa I know of you
know raising hand if there's a good
counter example that are run in the
blockchain space whether it's Nakamoto
consensus bit
coin proof of stake protocols they aim
to be adaptively secure and
communication efficient which requires
having some random selection of people
that's I think necessary but not
sufficient you have to do a lot of other
things to to gain adaptive security it's
like a hard problem but you need you
need this selection of active players
usually to be random so that's why it's
that's why it's over here
it's like far away from no random
selection
what no random selection well it's not
necessarily a future I mean well cuz you
know you you have to have a randomness
buchen right I mean like all these
protocols have to build like they're
proven it's like something you have to
bake into the
yeah yeah I mean like look if to take a
very specific example like if you look
at Algar and like it's the vrf broke
right then if the security was not you
know like if you could undermine if you
could predict other people to be RF
outputs then the security proof would
collapse right what just the adaptive
part yeah yeah well yeah you'd like it
wouldn't be secure against a adaptive
attacker anymore yeah
okay so sure
not that I know of oh well a I you know
it's it's a folk theorem so I I don't
even know if there's a formal proof for
it or a formal name but I think it's
like an idea that's that's out there
oh yeah it's different yeah okay and
then this was guess the question I was
anticipating you know is where's the
randomness in in Bitcoin well you know
basically the randomness is we don't
know who's gonna solve the puzzle next
so you know one way you can view the
computational puzzle and Bitcoin is it's
just a very expensive way to get a
randomized selection from the pool of
people participating at the pool of
miners essentially and it's it's
weighted or it's randomized over the
amount of computation that everybody's
performed so that's you know not the
only thing that proof-of-work is doing
you know it's probably doing more than
just randomness but that's one thing
that it provides is its it gives you a
random selection over all the miners
okay so how do we actually how can we
build a randomness speakin the first
thing people usually want is some sort
of cosmic or at least
who would be the reminder that would
succeed but there's a local fair we New
Age X is equal Y there is a lot of X's
that we go to the Y and choose in some
way one X well so you didn't think about
like why do they choose randomly if they
didn't choose randomly then the largest
miner would win every time and it
wouldn't be good right so everybody has
a incentive to actually which might
succeed is random they're both random
yeah okay so like I said the first thing
people usually want to do to build a
randomness beacon that doesn't work but
it's worth moving past is to extract the
randomness from some sort of natural
phenomenon that we believe humans can't
control so people say cosmic background
radiation solar flare activities
sometimes whether these are big
processes that aren't predictable by
humans or controllable by humans yet a
few small exceptions around weather so
they in theory like seem really
appealing as a way to generate random
values but they're not unanimous so you
know if if we want to have a randomness
beacon which is just the temperature and
Berkeley for the day really depends on
exactly which location in Berkeley
you're measuring you might you know
crossover from 72 to 73 degrees on one
side of the street to the other and of
course the thermometer that you're using
and everything else so sort of
interesting you sort of need a consensus
protocol around what your measurement of
the natural world is so it turns out I
think to not
very helpful it's not completely a pour
soap or soap poses well yeah but it it's
a like we have to measure it right and I
might measure it my my measuring
equipment might get a different
different reading than yours right
issues just that we may not agree on the
value right if you have like a trusted
party who can measure it then then it's
fine
so speaking of trusted parties there are
there have been some services that have
explicitly tried to be beacons that are
just run by a trusted party so NIST in
the u.s. this one has actually been
stood down I believe so it's not
available anymore
partly because nobody was using it but
while it was running they have an open
project actually to do sort of a beacon
2.0 but while it was running they
generated what they claimed were 512
bits of true randomness off of this they
had some physics set up in the basin in
Maryland and that was great but you know
you had to trust NIST that they were
actually running this and that they
weren't just making up the values to be
whatever they want what was every 60
seconds so you could get about 500 bits
every 60 seconds so it's pretty good but
you know the trust model was trust NIST
and then you know ran the org a lot of
people actually point to this which is
kind of scary because it's it's really
just a private company that runs this
and they don't even really provide a lot
of details about where they get their
random numbers so obviously not very
satisfactory solutions what
yeah from their lava lamps but again
these two sources I don't think that
brother no home no suspects list and
just do just take the to undo this and
well we'll come back to that yeah well
we'll come back to that but it's like
it's possible okay and then you know the
other thing people say a lot is like why
not just have the trusted party
demonstrate how they're generating their
randomness have them roll some dice
which is a great idea because it's
really old and it's still done all the
time so this is kind of the state of the
art for a lot of state lotteries FIFA
the NBA they still do lotteries you know
all the time that involve physical
things moving around and being drawn out
of hats or other places of course you
know like a good magician should be able
to fake this right everybody's seen a
magic show at some point in their life
and magicians do like far more
impressive sleight of hand than you know
picking a ball that they you know a
specific ball like specific ball out of
the out of the ball and in fact there
are lots and lots of cases where this
has actually happened
one of which turned into a movie that
happened in the 80s there was like
another one in Serbia two years ago that
involved a bunch of people going to jail
but these were you know state lotteries
that were on television were actually
rigged and in this case the attack was
really simple they were drawing
well they had a machine like a rotating
kind of plastic sphere and the ping-pong
balls would come out the bottom of it
and they just put lead weights in the
ping-pong balls that they wanted to come
out first and apparently that that
worked effectively enough for them to
make some money but then I guess they
went to jail one more story
because this is also a pretty
interesting one trying to do a physical
randomness display it can also fail kind
of accidentally and generate bad
randomness and the famous example the
first time the US did a draft lottery
this actually happened the reason it
happened if you look at these two
pictures you kind of noticed that they
they put all of these so there were 366
capsules in here one for each day of the
year and people were given a priority
priority order based on their birth date
so you notice though that the drum is in
this orientation when the guy's reaching
in to pull the capsules out but it was
you know on the horizontal orientation
when they were actually rotating it so
what happened is that they loaded all of
the capsules in order while it was
sitting vertically and then they turned
it over on its side and they rotated it
which like kind of worked but it didn't
it doesn't provide very much mixing kind
of left to right so when they flipped
the thing back over you know they mix
much more in one direction than up and
down the things that started on the
bottom we're generally still on the
bottom and then of course a human is
pulling them out and generally pulls
from the top first so I think it was
like five days after they published the
lottery results a statistician who
worked at NIST did a scatter plot and
ran some statistical tests and said
there's a really big problem these
results aren't random there was a bias
against men who were born later in the
year and the Pentagon the US military
looked at this and said it would cause
too much chaos if we basically tried to
redo this so they classified it for 30
years and then they published their
report so we sort of know what happened
now but it's just kind of interesting
that I mean I
suppose you know with modern crypto this
problem things may be matter is slightly
less because we know about extractor
functions and and things but you know
it's it's hard to gauge how much
randomness you're really getting out of
these big public displays one other
example which is really interesting
actually the there's a phenomenon that
was very very common in the u.s. about a
hundred years ago called the numbers
game and it was basically a lottery that
was run by organized crime
so lotteries state lotteries in the u.s.
didn't exist until the 1950s they were
illegal everywhere and as a result since
people still like to gamble the
lotteries were run locally by organized
crime so there were all these different
crime lords in each city and it was
actually the number one source of
revenue for organized crime so before
drug-dealing and extortion and
everything else they made more money by
going around and selling these tickets
and basically you just pick three
numbers and you bet you know this is
just how much you bet on each set of
numbers and then they would come back
the next day and they would pay you if
you had hit the right the winning three
numbers for the day and how did they
pick which three numbers one this is
like organized crime so they had a trust
problem they had to convince people that
it was honest so they did something very
simple they just took the last three
stocks listed on the New York Stock
Exchange and they took the low-order
digit of each stock price and those are
the three numbers and if you predicted
those right then you know then your your
policy would win so it's actually not a
bad idea and it's it's still you know
using asset prices more generally is
still like a very real idea but the
problem if you do this at like a very
high level so people on the street
betting five dollars it's a fair bet
that they can't manipulate stock prices
very easily but at the high level
there's ways to manipulate stock prices
so if you're able to make trades at the
end of the day there's a lot of
different ways that you can push numbers
up or down so this is kind of like close
yeah you can yeah high frequency traders
can can do it like if you give them a
budget and you say I want you know the
price of Apple to end in a nine tomorrow
like they can they can do it the
high-frequency people can go last right
so it's it's hard for a you know like a
later aider to do it but the the big
firms especially if only one of them
wants to do it they can do it right so
this is like close but doesn't doesn't
quite work okay so that's you know kind
of it for story time and now I'm going
to talk about crypto a good time to
leave this okay so I'll basically show
you three different families of
generating randomness that's
cryptographically verifiable in kind of
the the multi-party settings so not yet
the full permission this kind of
blockchain setting so the classic one is
a commit reveal protocol where you know
we're just dealing with three parties
here every party commits to a random
value this is a cryptographic commitment
that's hiding so you can everybody can
publish their commitment it doesn't give
you any information about what's been
committed too so you have some deadlines
everybody commits to a random value and
then everybody opens their commitment so
they reveal what they committed to and
you somehow combine everybody's random
values you can hash them together XOR
them whatever and that's basically the
shared random value that everybody
produces okay so this is very very
simple the problem is that the last
party to reveal ends up being in sort of
a privileged position so in a in a
privileged position
you know not single yeah right well so
in it's totally synchronous and yeah
sure
if you have to send before you receive
that's hard though I mean that requires
it's very hard to enforce yeah okay so
why do I say Carol's in a privileged
position here so at the time when Alice
and Bob have revealed their values Carol
is able to compute what the final result
will be right because Carol knows her
value which she hasn't published Alice
and Bob can't compute the final value
because they don't know what Carol's
contribution is so you know carol has
two advantages here she knows what the
outputs gonna be first exactly so but
and you know at this moment in time
carol has not revealed so nobody can
compute the result except Carol right I
thought that the type of RA in a review
yeah is after all the commit okay so
Carol is committed yeah actually she so
I should be clear these are not like
this is not one synchronous time step in
another this is just a weak weak
synchrony here so so you're saying like
carol has already committed to her value
right okay so the two problems right
would you agree that Carol will learn
the result first if she's the last to
reveal but what do you do in the case
that Carol doesn't publish if that
forces the protocol to be rerun and
Carol has gained right a 1-bit choice on
accept this value and say this value say
they're just picking a winner of the
if this.value says alice is the winner
Carol can not publish and then if you
restart she again has a fresh 1/3 chance
to win right so being able to abort
actually gives you the ability to
control the final result or to influence
the final result
yeah so it's it's true that exactly okay
so you can sort of fix this if you have
a penalty which is you know what people
have tried to do in the blockchain space
there was this is one of the early
papers about Bitcoin which was really I
guess Stefan's not not here today but it
was his work with some colleagues they
they showed how to actually do penalties
for the first time in Bitcoin
so really neat there's been a lot of
other follow up work on this showing
that you can kind of fix this but it
requires having a penalty ok so if you
have a penalty if Carol doesn't reveal I
mean you need a penalty for everybody
then this might be made to work this is
just like her random value and this is
the you know the opening to her
commitment group and then you could say
in the next round she still might be ok
right I mean it still might be
worthwhile for her yeah I mean if the
punishment is worse than the loss of
losing the lottery then people will
reveal that's the assumption but that
requires having some ability to punish
people but you need you need some way to
punish ok another way you can do this
you this is a little bit more
complicated cryptographically but you
know basically a similar protocol
everybody commits to a random value and
then you also encrypt missing something
here ok yeah this this new the slide got
cut off or something missing but the key
idea here you commit to your value you
also so Alice will encrypt to Bob's
public key and
ooh Carol's public-key two different
secret shares and then you also need an
encryption of what your committed value
is so there's kind of one thing
I apologize missing from the slide and
then you have a proof that everything's
actually consistent so you have to prove
that you actually encrypted secret
shares and that when combined those
secret shares will open your commitment
which again there needs to be like an
encryption of this RA here for this to
work okay but you know basically same
idea everybody commits to a value but
now you publish all this extra data and
the reason that's useful is that if we
get to the same situation if Carol tries
to abort and not open her commitment
there's enough information here so Alice
and Bob sort of published their secret
shares and then Alice and Bob are able
to actually recover Carol's committed
value if carol didn't publish it yeah so
this is important so now you're sort of
assuming an honest majority which is you
know it's a different trust assumption
than before
but you're able to recover and you don't
need an explicit penalty so this thing
if there's an honest majority this
protocol should always finish which is
kind of the you know the you know
generally that I think there's an
impossibility result that for well for
MPC generally you need an honest
majority to be sure that the things
going to finish in that nobody you know
will learn the result if other people
don't learn it
yeah yeah
so there's some kind of you know
somewhat related ideas so I think
they're all forms of MPC but for the
definitive blockchain they do threshold
signatures to generate randomness as a
group and it has the same property that
if a subset if a minority goes offline
or doesn't participate the majority can
still produce the same result okay and
then the other paradigm which I guess
I'll talk about more how long am I
supposed to go for by the way
what we have on the schedule okay okay
all right I have to at least at least
show this so this is the the really
slick kind of modern way to do it that
dates to oh I don't have the citation on
this slide it's it safe - I believe 2016
a paper by Lenstra and was Olaf's key so
this protocol is really really simple
everybody just publishes their random
contribution directly so there's no
commitments there's no crypto at all you
just publish some random value and then
you compute the beacon output as some
combination of everybody's random input
run through a delay function and that's
it so that's the whole protocol and this
delay function needs to have this
property that the minimum feasible time
to compute it is longer than the window
that participants have to publish their
share okay so this is a very important
assumption that this delay has to
actually be slow to compute but once you
make that assumption this protocol just
sort of works and can't be manipulated
why so if we sort of if we go back to
this point and and freeze you know Carol
might even see Alice and Bob's random
contributions and she can pick whatever
she wants but she can't actually compute
what the impact of any value she picks
is on the final result because the time
to actually compute this combination in
delay is so long that if she tries to
compute it she'll miss the deadline it's
kind of subtle but it's like a very very
powerful powerful idea that if you can
make this thing slow to compute you can
put people into this kind of no-win
situation where they're either
publishing something and they have no
idea what the impact will be or by the
time they figure out what the impact
will be it's it's too late
not the computing power but the
computing speed but we'll yeah so we'll
we'll drill down on that so this is this
is a strong assumption that you have to
have you know she can't be able to speed
this computation up but you know we've
been working a lot on on this problem
yeah
so you basically need you know you need
some like partial synchrony bound and
you need your VD F to be much bigger
than that but you need some you need
some ability to say like this thing was
you know published on time or it wasn't
published on time but I guess at that
point that's just denial of service
right she can't she can't abort in an
intelligent way that will have any
bearing on the outcome but that's
definitely true that you know that this
deadline is functionally a little bit
different here in the right in the Box
chain setting this is fairly natural you
just sort of say like it has to be
published by this block you know yes or
no and some other settings it might not
be quite as obvious how to enforce this
deadline
Oh a time commitment yeah ah so I so I
had it I had I had a slide for this
actually but I thought it was like too
deep in the weeds but I'm glad you
brought it up so there's yeah so there's
a old idea of how you could do this
protocol to where you it's still a
one-shot sort of well that's actually
not a one-shot protocol though it's
still - because you still normally
commit and reveal right you all need
right all right yeah well it's it's two
rounds but Vidia then you don't have to
actually compute the thing yeah yeah so
it's it's a really interesting protocol
I mean it uses a different like dough a
primitive slightly yeah you still need a
deadline
yeah so it's definitely like a downside
to this approach is that you know even
though it's communication efficient kind
of maximally cuz everybody only has to
publish one thing you have to wait
somebody has to actually compute this
thing
[Music]
advantage of this over the threshold
there's no threshold here like so
actually let me show you my next slide
if it helps so I mean the main advantage
of with commit and reveal or with is
these this delay protocol or Lenstra and
Wesolowski called it unicorn the trust
model is that you only need one one
party to be honest here right whereas
the NPC based approaches you need an
honest majority but you know the
assumptions are much stronger either you
need some way to punish people who abort
or in the delay case the vdf case you
need to make some stronger assumptions
about limits on hardware and how fast
you can compute something does that
answer your question about why why it's
sort of well like the idea of how to
actually instantiate this in the
blockchain space is basically that you
apply it to the entire block and that
way like anybody who wants to
participate just has to get any
transaction in the block and then
they've sort of influenced the result
that makes sense so so it's it's kind of
a little bit less explicit than this
there aren't named parties the parties
or anybody who is publishing any data in
a block yeah and this these things are
really every transaction in the block so
you just have to get a transaction and
then you participate in
right so the bump in time you sit
properly then even if the doesn't speak
oh yeah yeah which is yeah exactly which
is why I was saying like you you don't
actually need to know the set of
participants you just go with whoever
publishes a transaction in the block and
as long as you know somebody does then
you're kind of okay okay so that's kind
of why this is a maybe an appealing
protocol let me well let's see so I
should be getting to the end actually
that I could talk for a lot longer about
this let me uh let me skip let me skip
talking about the blockchain stuff I'd
be happy to present it later if people
are interested let me just talk about
the the crypto primitive that the new
crypto primitive and tell you sort of
where that's at okay so kind of a new
crypto primitive that's evolved in the
last two years basically three different
groups were working on it kind of
ironically I was working on it with the
group at Stanford we had sort of the the
least good construction but we published
our paper first so the definitions a
name of we know sort of taken from
mostly from our paper as I'll show you
the constructions that are actually the
most promising we came from the to other
folks working on it
so vdf is verifiable tool a function
it's a crypto primitive basically
there's a function that you can evaluate
on any input X gives you an output and a
proof of a correctness and then
obviously given this proof the input in
the output you should be able to check
that they're valid and it should be very
efficient to verify okay so you know
verifiable means more efficient to
verify than just redoing the thing
yourself and this evaluation should be
sequential should it should take T steps
and
she is a parameter that you can specify
so if you want the function to take you
know at least two million sequential
steps you can just specify that and then
you can pick that number based on what
the real-world delay that you want is
just a security parameter standard
crypto parameter okay so the sort of
historical note is that you know before
I guess 2018 people have thought about
doing every combination of two of the
three of BDNF but not all three at the
same time in particular if you just want
a delay function you just have to
iterate a hash function that's pretty
easy if you just want something that's
hard but not sequentially hard lots and
lots of examples but you know you
computing the discrete log as one and
then a little more obscure if you want
something that is efficient to verify
and provides a sequential delay not a
unique function there were these
constructions called proofs of
sequential work that I believe we're
first published in 2010 haven't really
been used for much and sort of use a
different different technique but
they're it's a pretty cool construction
the idea is you build a hash chain but
you actually add a bunch of edges so
each node here is the hash of all of its
predecessors this thing is a depth
robust graph and that way and then you
randomly open you you get to this point
you sort of do a Fiat sameer thing you
hash this and then randomly reveal a
bunch of these edges to check and the
depth robust graph gives you the
property that unless you cheat in lots
and lots of these there's still a very
long path in the graph which means it's
sequential so kind of the key key part
of it is the depth robust graph which
also makes them kind of unwieldy but
it's a it's a cool construction
that's better yeah yes yeah yeah so it's
been improved since the original
construction it's still kind of I think
worse than the modern BDF stuff in
practice okay so how do you how do you
build a vdf that has all three
properties at once the sort of obvious
solution is you just take you take
something that's a delay function and
you use any sort of generic verifiable
computation to get a succinct proof so
this works if not very efficient if you
do this kind of naively if you just like
if you tried to do a you know proof
using lib snark of like two million
hash functions in a row the proving time
would probably be quite long so you know
by itself this is proves that this is
possible but doesn't give you a very
practical system let me just show you
the one that actually turns out to work
it's a very very simple actually you
just take your input you raise it to the
power two to the T so it's just T
squarings of that input in a row and
then you have to have some way of
verifying this I think I'll skip showing
this whole proof let me give you the
high level intuition well kind of the
amazing thing until 2018 we didn't know
how to do this proof you know in a in a
more specific way than you know generic
techniques and then within two weeks in
June 2018 there were two separate papers
published that had two totally different
ways to do this proof by you know to two
separate people and since then a lot
more people have looked at it we haven't
found really anything else besides kind
of rehashing zuv these two general ideas
so kind of neat that out of nowhere we
sort of came up with well we I shouldn't
say we is to take any credit I'm not
either of those people no no no they
have like very different structures the
two proofs which is why it was really
really interesting and like like I said
we've looked since and you know we
found anything else so it almost seems
like there's you know two different ways
to do it but the I'll skip the algebra
and the interest of time but basically
this is the Peter Zack proof and this
one is set sort of iterative so you
split the chain in half it starts with
just a way to check that this is the
same exponent chain as this so you kind
of split split it in half but you know
the really cool observation is that you
can actually repeat that and you can do
a kind of binary search and you know
logarithmic number of steps you can
prove that the whole chain was computed
correctly so very very neat it's if
you're interested you should definitely
read Ben Wesolowski paper too because
it's a totally different proof structure
that's very very elegant and cool so we
know how to do it on paper now you know
PDFs are still not a thing in practice
yet so I'll just sort of highlight the
challenges that we're sort of debating
so one of them is which group you want
to do this in I presented it mod n
that's the most natural one to do it in
an RSA group you can do it in any group
where nobody knows the order so you know
the classic way to do that is to have a
trusted set up which to chooses to large
prime numbers and multiplies them
obby who had to leave today but he and
others have been working on doing this
using MPC trying to scale up MPC to have
like a thousand parties as their goal
compute an RSA number which is pretty
cool it's beyond the bounds of what
we've really has been done before but
you know so if that comes together then
we can use RSA groups which are really
well known to do this so you have ufo's
idea I don't think anyone seriously
pursuing but it's interesting the the
other way to do it is to use class
groups which are a different group
structure hasn't been as far as I know
used in practice for anything yet but it
it was published you know with regards
to crypto a while ago now but this is a
waiting
a group of unknown order without a
trusted setup so all you have to do is
choose a prime number you know public
setup there's no no trusted setup and
then you have a new class group to use I
should say the you know the really
interesting challenge here is to use a
vdf you have to reason very carefully
about how quickly an attacker can build
hardware to compute this function so we
have more confidence that we can reason
about how much you can speed up squaring
mod n that's a relatively simple
function that's been looked at a lot in
people have built hardware before for it
the class group arithmetic we don't know
as much there's a startup called Chia
that's actually doing a contest to see
how fast people can do this in software
and the goal is to move to hardware and
hopefully I guess and have a future
contest there's sort of some economic
questions like who should compute the
vdf the etherium foundation sort of used
it as a public good so they're planning
to spend on the order of a few million
dollars building hardware and
maintaining that hardware and running it
to actually well to build a beacon using
a PDF for aetherium 2.0 for both for
consensus and for smart contracts to be
able to use but it's kind of interesting
because like on paper its scalable only
one party has to compute the PDF but in
practice you know you still have to
spend millions of dollars to build
hardware and it's not that useful if you
don't if you haven't built hardware and
that's like a big one-off upfront cost
that somebody has to pay so it's nice
that you know the theory and foundation
and a couple of other cryptocurrency
foundations have pledged to donate money
but it's not clear for other
applications you know how how you would
solve this problem and the last thing
I'll leave you with kind of an
interesting interesting challenge people
in crypto have worried a lot about
scaling doing a lot of brute force
they haven't reasoned too much before
about how much you can accelerate a
single computation which are very very
different problems if you want to build
one piece of hardware that solves the
one problem really really quickly
you can start thinking about sort of
very exotic
well exotic semiconductors lots of
different things that really the crypto
community hasn't had to deal with before
so hopefully we're gaining some new
expertise on that and not making a you
know huge miscalculations and how fast
stuff can be computed but it's
interesting that that we're at this
point now okay why don't I take
questions
[Applause]